what is a perfectly productive day in
the life of Todd Howard look like
so uh maybe not perfectly but just like
a perfectly average product
uh what what are you a morning person
evening person is it chaos is it pretty
regular
uh I'm in a good I'm on a good flow
right now I'm still doing a lot of stuff
so there's things I'm like executive
producing and then
you know Starfield I'm directing so I
sort of view that as that's an everyday
thing
um fortunately I get to do a lot of
stuff from
look at the TV show we're making and
um this Indiana Jones game that's being
developed at machine games we have to
look at that
um but you know the best really day or
before I feel as fulfilling is
um get to play some of a game the game
will say Starfield get to play some of
the Starfield look at the problem set of
what it is doing
and then get in a room with
the other developers that I work closely
with and we solve that problem together
so
that's the most rewarding thing when you
can say okay what do we want this to do
what's the what's the Real Player
experience we want what are all the
pieces in front of us where you you know
the actual tangible pieces as opposed to
the beginning the pie and the sky part
is always fun
but it's like anything is possible
that's fun but it's not
rewarding in the same way because you
haven't solved something whereas these
are the elements you have to play with
how do we make this all work together
and you come out of at the end of the
day like now that feels great
so brainstorming about specific big
picture both big picture and and very
specific detail of a game that's not
working something's not working you want
to fix it that kind of stuff
because you feel like okay you've made
tangible progress on the actual build of
the game or something you played in the
beginning of the day didn't feel great
you've figured out a solution with a
group of people like it's always with a
group
and then the next day you're like yeah
that was
that worked out who's on the team is it
designers Engineers all the about
artists voice over so internal to the
studio it's you know a lot of
programming a lot of art you have design
which breaks into some you know Quest
design writing systems design who are
like doing all the treasure and the loot
and the syst and the skill systems yeah
and then level design is making the
spaces like those that you'll play
through production is a big part of it
the producers who organize everything
um I can't remember if I mentioned art a
lot of artists
um QA staff as well they're hugely
valuable in saying hey we broke your
game in these magical ways what are you
gonna do about it
is the loot design team still hiring how
do I apply it seems like the most always
tough always I mean that all of this
seems like a super fun it is you know
what it's the best then you have audio
um and
it it by far is is the greatest job you
could possibly have and so if you're
into like technology it's great if
you're in the storytelling and
creativity and art it's great and it's
really the gaming you know the
combination of that
and like like I mentioned to you offline
I think of video games I mean to me he's
brought thousands of hours of happiness
and so when you're designing the game
whatever you're doing you have a part to
playing a thing that's going to bring
like Millions hundreds of millions of
Hours of Happiness to people
and you know crazy right it is and I'm
gonna I'm gonna play play you saying
that back to our team because you know
people forget your head's down you're
trying to solve these problems and then
you do forget how many people
it touches like even tiny decisions you
make tiny little things you create yeah
it's weird I wish there was a way to
like
um like I would notice things in the
video game and it's like huh okay like
there's a if it feels good but you don't
get that signal it the the creator
doesn't get that signal I wish they did
um I guess you could get that signal by
you know why is Lex stuck in this room
like digging through the loop we do get
we do now get a lot of good data on what
the players are doing enjoying a knot
well we we know where they've been and
where they've died and how long they
play in certain sections and we can sort
of tell outside of people just telling
us on forums or calling or other things
um we can tell for some data where
people are dropping off or having a you
know we can tell if there's a key
frustration point
do you ever
think about making people feel like
human feelings when they play like
designing
like make them feel fear or excitement
anger
uh longing loneliness with stuff all the
above yeah of course the big one
I like to say is the video games give
you is pride
outside of other you know if you watch
movies or things like that like yeah but
you never think like look what I did
yeah and that feeling of like
accomplishment and pride in what you did
where you overcame
you talked about going back to a game
that like those are real feelings of
like accomplishment
that I've felt in games uh that I've
played
and
when we get to see a player feel that
um it's really really special
the other one is there is a
you know there is an escape or to be
someone else that's more powerful in
what in our games that you are in real
life that gives you a confidence or a
perspective
um
we're doing one next week but we've done
a number of Make-a-Wish visits kids who
could wish for anything
and they want to come and I want to see
the next game and meet the creators and
see how you do it and they come with
their family
um and it is like the greatest thing
that we do
and
it reminds you of like how important it
is and the other really awesome thing is
that you can see like the family change
by the end of the day like they don't
they didn't even realize what it meant
to their child or what would into it and
it's just that to me is like
been been involved with that foundation
for a number of years and it's been
really good you know reminder
of how lucky we are and in general for
young people that sense of
accomplishment is hard to find
I mean yeah where they they don't not
everybody has it in the outlets that
real life provides well that's the thing
I mean the world is cruel to when you're
young
nobody takes you seriously you don't get
like that's why you everybody always
wants to grow up and get old as good as
possible it's the hardest
it's hard and then video games allow you
I mean to build that sense of confidence
a sense of Pride and something that's
why when people talk uh down to video
games like it's a culture and so on I
it's it's not
it misses out on that really deeply
meaningful thing especially with like
single player there's some darker
aspects to multiplayer that people
create communities and you know it can
it can go off the rails a bit but the
actual experience of the game
um especially one we used to stick with
for a while that's that's really
beautiful